There's a great saying that wikipedia
works really well in practice,
just not in theory,
and that is true wikipedia success is so
singular,
so spectacular that figuring out whether
it's a model for anything other than
Wikipedia is a puzzle that even the
folks behind Wikipedia have faced as
they've tried to do wiki search,
Wiki news and [inaudible] Harry at
different times,
but the idea of having a scheme where
the day to day governance,
the day to day edits,
whether done for substance to improve
the truth level of an article in the
view of the editor or done for process,
oh,
that edit shouldn't have been made a
breaks.
The following rule,
I'm going to revert it to have the
people doing that be members of the
public at large is an extraordinary
devolution of responsibility out to
people who are in one way or another
implicitly or explicitly sort of taking
an oath to subscribe to the principles
behind Wikipedia of neutrality,
of fairness,
of learning,
kind of the values of the enlightenment
and cannot survive itself over the long
haul.
I don't know.
As you get more and more importance
attached to Wikipedia,
more and more places that draw from
wikipedia as a source of data,
whether it's something like the Wolfram
Alpha knowledge engine or google to
assemble basic facts for results in a
search,
there may be more and more reason for
entities to want to gain the results.
If you could just put yourself in the
Guinness Book of World Records for
having the longest beard or something
and you don't actually have to grow
anything,
it's like,
well,
why not?
I'll vote myself rich.
These are problems that wikepedia has
had to deal with so far,
relatively successfully.
And uh,
there's a level of humility that I think
it has to maintain in order to recognize
new problems,
to recognize where there might be
structural forms of bias or
discrimination going on and to be able
to endure the more targeted intentional
attempts to basically poison the well of
truth that wikipedia at least aspires to
be.
What would I propose as a longer term
way of shoring it up?
I think we should solve a problem with a
problem we haven't really figured out,
uh,
in the early 21st century,
what to do with kids who are in school
for hours at a time,
every day sort of warehoused in daycare.
I think it would be wonderful to make as
part of the curriculum from say sixth
grade onward,
part of your task and it will be graded
on,
is to edit and make the case for your
edits to an article on a service like
wikipedia.
And then we'll have new ranks of people
being supervised by teachers who are
working on the articles and on the
product.
And that may be even we'll apprentice to
the norms by which you have an argument
over what is true and what isn't.
And maybe some of them will choose to
continue on his wikipedia guns,
uh,
even after the assignment is over.
So to me,
if I think of an advanced civics class,
it's great to learn that there are three
branches of government and you know,
x vote gets you a veto,
but a overrides a veto.
But having the civics of a collective
hallucination like wikipedia also be
part of the curriculum,
I think would be valuable.